able to make any contact on that and that was
Philip Den that made that pu made that play
from the goal line out it was Fabro from straight
away sticked aside by rck through dowy in his 16th
season with the Kings here's brunstrom into the
Nashville Zone cutting wide kicked out by Soros
good play there mind Ken we heard you only allowed
one goal boost yeah I shouldn't have counted too
there's Kamp in with a shot good speed there by
Kee head is up all the way shoots it right from
the top of the circle oh yeah right off the bar
here's Evangelista down the right wing heading
it back out to the point for Roman Yosi Yosi in
with a shot save made by rck there's brunstrom
into the Nashville Zone sh was blocked Rock
to the far Corner Trevor Lewis he just got
a simp ify nice play there by duah duah cross
eyes shot by Anderson Dolan turned aside by us
SOS beautiful black hand play there from duah
here's Fabro towards the net turned aside by
R runr with it has turot on his left run
for it with a shot he scores one nothing Los
Angeles well the fourth line for the LA Kings B
comes up large here's the battle level Evangelista
loses the puck with the pressure coming from turot
and then grundstrom with Saros the much smaller
goenda it to the far side yeah you can tell
Grom I think at at first he was thinking past
Park picked off at Center here come the Kings
Fier with a shot knocked out by zaros Anderson
Dolan with the rebound opportunity another save
oh what a save there well we wanted La P to shoot
the puck a little bit more you know just funnel
pucks to the net and there's the shot there's a
rebound and you got people going hard to the net
and Dolan going there looking for a opportunity
but the pressure coming from the backside one
of our guys our colleagues in the studio Anson
Conor you were his first professional head coach
yeah I apologize to him all the time leading the
Predators one nothing and now a short-handed
break for decision moving in stop rebound and
second save by reck oh what a stop so Nashville
back at full strength shots 1813 Predators Kings
have a one- nothing lead shot score now two
nothing turot is first in the National Hockey
League on Trevor Lewis grabs the puck
there bsh exactly thank you wow what a
finish what a pass here by Moore but you
know Bush we should go back and watch
how does Moore have so much space coming
through the middle of the ice there and
then there you see that quick little hands
from the Baltimore skip Jacks 9192 the prior
season Alfie turkot was the leading scorer
played for Barry TRS at 85 points and now
his son Alex with his first and it's your
go now the Predators from right back Tyson
Barry forsberg gets this Puck to the net and
Barry just turns around and quickly gets it to
the net and I think Ric has a sight line to this
puck just wasn't able to squeeze those legs tight
enough oh Yosi made a heck of a play there bu
she got drilled from behind and he stayed right
with it from our AT&T after review there was
incidental contact with the goalie we have no
goal dowy back for Los Angeles pu bounced
away from Lewis coming out in front with it
and a save by rck he didn't know where
that puck was he was looking over your
shoulder that's a positional save right
there for David rck he's been sharp for
LA and they seem to be more decisive
here on this second power play the S
work by K Here Comes Kar with the King
shorthanded moving in and the save by
SOS a short-handed Breakaway opportunity
for kopar here's for bird back into the
king Zone Puck kept it at the line
by Novak half minute to go on the
dowy minor Kings leading the predators two
nothing here's Yosi redirect from nqu missed
the net comes back across Novak stopped
by rck Novak with it once again down low
now the return Puck along the goal line sent
back out to Novak here's nqu shoots off the
post Yosi with it straight
away dowy getting set to
return penalty expires High Quist with the puck
dropping it back off Kings at full strength nice
read There by Mikey Anderson and now shot by
forsberg stopped the pass across broken up no
back with it for Nashville defended by kopar now
Nightwish shoveling it back out forsberg and broke
score and somehow forsberg we talked about nobody
getting to the front of the net forsberg goes to
the front of the net watch the battle level there
he pulls this Puck and he's able to throw those
hands up towards the crossbar as he gets it he
pulls it and rck not able to move from right to
left it's not a power play goal but it may
as well be tired on the forsburg goal here
24th at the 515 Mark of the third period here's
Cody last back out shot off the post from Noak
and then David po hired trotz as the first head
coach to Nashville and now Trot succeeded him
as general manager of the Predators Puck
out in front scar 31 Los Angeles Trevor
Lewis his first in 17 games effort by turot
there's Byfield who has an EXT ended shift
Byfield stays with it turot finds it and then
byfield's the one that passes his puck right
out watch the play turcot's going to come
in and then Byfield with this Long Reach is
going to find this puck right there what a play
good news for Nashville there's still another TV
timeout to come so you can address some of your
your big guys during that break there's no back
SL cross passing from score it's now a 3-2
game thomaso scores for the second straight
game for Nashville now your mind mindset
changes they got control here and then it's
stolen I think it ends up being thomasino's
the guy that stole the H I believe from
copar what a pass was that Yosi that made
that pass wow what a pass what a play
battle for the puck behind the Los Angeles
net szin shouldered by Den Puck sent down
towards the empty net it's in 42 Los Angeles
the former Nashville creditor fiala into the
empty net 45 in that area they could not get
off the ice it was a time earlier when Moore
had a chance to get it out cleanly didn't
and they got stuck out there so this one
going between the post is the allstar game
forit can be a good reset for him and see
if he can find his game once again oh another
stop by rck as the kings are going to win for
the first time of their last five only the
third of the last 17 for2 the final here in
Nashville